do you get the free grill off the rip
last time i went to houston to shoot the
videos and we were just running and
gunning like we did three videos four
videos in like 48 hours so you know i
didn't get to ain't get my [ __ ] yet but
i'm definitely gonna get him how is the
grill business cause i feel like it's
made
feel like there was like a small little
time where it kind of died out but it's
back man this is uh you know it's as a
businessman in any type of business
there's always gonna be cycles of course
things are going to come and go you got
to adjust to the cycle you got to adjust
to the consumer you got to try to find a
way to you know reconnect with the
consumers and you know the cultures will
dictate the grills you know so we can
sit there and sell them all day we can
do whatever we come we come up with all
the new styles all day but if the
culture don't want it then it is dead so
it was a time when you know it's like
grills came from being an underground
thing to being mainstream to being
everybody's got grills and it's no
longer something cultural is now uh
everyday mainstream fad or a trend with
all fairs and trends they come and go so
when it became the national trend you
know it's like the underground and the
culture the streets was like man [ __ ]
this
once nelly dropped grills did it was
like
well it's kind of like that that brought
the peak and then it took it to the next
level and then it was like oh my god
where did we go
but then they came back when the youth
came with them yeah the new generation
was like man i want some grills and they
come in and get grills they brought it
back to where now i feel like
it's a a mainstay of jewelry where
change definitely you need the grill
earring grill help me with the hygiene
perspective of grills because a lot of
grown-ass men i know have metal in their
mouth yes have the worst [ __ ] breath
on the planet this is this is a known
thing yeah i'm like bro get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] backwood grill
breath bruh yeah right man how do you
prevent the breath from smelling like
[ __ ] if you have a grill proper hygiene
whatever normal hygiene is recommended
which is brushing your teeth two times a
day two to three times a day but who
brush your teeth three times a day two
times a day and clean your grills out
you know some people eat with them or
they smoke with them or they drink
coffee or whatever with them well think
about it you you're doing that and
you're not cleaning them and stuff
staying in there it's creating bacteria
it's gonna stink and your breath is
gonna stink and a lot of people they'll
put on the grills and to them it's a oh
i don't need to brush my teeth because i
got grills it's it's a mental thing it's
a mental thing when you feel like you
don't have to but it's also to me you
just got to get on the schedule no
matter what i brush my teeth in the
morning when i wake up whether i feel
like a stink well i don't know whether i
ate something that morning or eight
something the night before or anything
with normal human [ __ ] right i always
brush your teeth in the morning i always
brush your teeth at night but them stain
grills man they some see but let me tell
you man let me tell you this cory blunt
shout out to corey blunt og triple og
slab originator man okay
he had permanent goatee
he went to the feds for 30 years
came out got new gold teeth so he got
the old ones removed his teeth
underneath pearly white nothing wrong
with them so
you can have permanent grills for 30
plus years and nothing go wrong with
your teeth now most people who get
permanent grills they not flossing or
brushing the teeth every day so of
course if you don't floss you don't
brush your teeth you don't take care of
yourself it's gonna get rotten and you
can see the horror stories of people
with permanent gold teeth they take them
out man it ain't what's up not good and
this is just normal grown-up [ __ ] that's
regular [ __ ] though you're supposed to
brush your teeth right now right that's
washer ass brush we tell our kids right
before we bring them to school you brush
your teeth
like come on that's the first [ __ ]